und bei mir im studio ist james die
bindernagel ehemalige us-botschafter in
deutschland 1996 97 genau hier in bonn
auf kosten der armen
wir müssen beginnen bei der bedeutung
dieses verfahrens das ist gar keine
frage wem nützt das eigentlich ist das
nicht noch einmal so zu sagen
preiswertes rampenlicht für entstand das
ist auch kein ausweg werden darunter das
wichtigste ist ja auch die verfassung es
geht um die verfassung ist es keinen rex
verfahren ist ein verfassungs frauen und
das ist dann auch kein kampf der
verfassung auch richtiges oder jump
gegen den verfassungen und gewinnt
kommen wir sozusagen zu dem vorwurf der
ist ja durchaus gravierend anstiftung
zum aufruhr es gibt auch anders als bei
den vorherigen impeachment tatsächlich
nur einen anklagevorwurf das heißt wir
haben mit einem konzentrierten verfahren
zu rechnen
wie groß ist nach wie vor der schaden
die sechste januar angerichtet hat für
die demokratien usa es hat einige
schaden auch für die märkische
demokratie das zeigt dass dann auch ein
präsident kann auch einen wahlbetrug
behaupten und dann auch musizieren auch
unter sich vorwürfen und dann auch gegen
den capitol unser kapital das die
demokratie auch kämpfen das ist auch
wirklich sehr sehr ernst
und das wird etwas sein das auch
durchaus noch zu bleiben wird auch und
nach wellen hart kommen wir noch mal zu
diesen juristischen zweifeln sie haben
das angesprochen die republikaner
argumentieren mit der nicht vorhandenen
verfassungsmäßigkeit dieses verfahrens
sie sagen das ist nur vorgeschoben aber
trotzdem das wird irgendwann zu lösen
sein das verfahren selber gibt es jetzt
die verfassung verlegt gelegt jetzt ist
auch klar dass anklage erhebt würden
pietsch und vom haus mussten auch der
senat auch keinen an erfahrung haben das
auch klar dass auch kein keine ablenkung
das wichtig sei es die zukunft der
republikanische partei und die
verfassung merkel
er trump hat ja abgelehnt den wunsch der
demokraten nachzukommen persönlich
aufzutreten was erwarten sie sozusagen
eigentlich als ich hatte das in der
anmoderation als spektakel bezeichnet
wird es ein spektakel werden oder eher
eine kleinere vorstellung der mann auch
ist als lügner deshalb schwierig zu
sehen was ja dann auch glaubt oder nicht
glaubt aber dass er würde dann auch
seine leute hinter sich haben und es
geht um den 74 millionen wurde die auch
viel publikum partei im wahlkampf
gekämpft und die gehen als weiter und
wie steht das auge und er steht auch
hinter den und die stehen auch hinter
ihm mehr oder weniger kann man jetzt
schon absehen dass die zwei drittel
mehrheit nicht erreicht werden kann weil
zu viele republikanische senatorin mit
den demokraten stimmen müssten danach
sieht es bisher nicht aus fünf haben
sozusagen beim aufnahmeverfahren
mitgestimmt aber es müssten 12 sein
damit man sozusagen tatsächlich das
engagement erfolgreich durchziehen kann
warum also dann noch also stichwort
strategie und taktik warum also dann
doch noch das verfahren wenn man am ende
nicht erfolgreich sein kann
ja natürlich auch das wichtige erfahrung
hat er nach zwei ausgaben ersten
erhebung verwahrung ist auch klar dass
er nicht mehr am abend ist aber das
zweite ist dass er dann auffangen also
neue bewerbungen auch für ein amt in
amerika auch verband sein könnte das ist
das wichtigste
kann er dann auch nicht mehr antreten
auch in den regierungen regierung
aber dieses ist erst zu erreichen wenn
sozusagen die mehrheit dafür da ist
sehen sie denn irgendwelche anzeichen
dass es jetzt zu einem
überraschungseffekt kommt was müsste
herr mcconnell tun damit vielleicht eine
sozusagen nennenswerte anzahl von
republikanern noch einmal in sich geht
das ist das interessanteste frage weil
es geht auch intern in der bibel
ricanische partei gibt es 17 leute die
auch sagen nein ich stimme auch für die
verfassung nicht für die partei das kann
man nicht voraussagen aber es sieht so
dass sie diese 17 leute die 17 senatoren
nicht da sind
das geht nicht mit dem rechtswesen
wächst erfahrung ist eine politische
frage
und als die zukunft sagt republikanische
partei im griff wir stehen im grunde
genommen jetzt an einer zeit wo die
republikaner sagen wir haben jetzt schon
die nächste wahl im blick und die
demokraten sagen wir müssen schauen dass
wir dieses land eine zumindest der
demokratische präsident joe biden müsste
das im blick haben insofern die frage
ist es jetzt schlau von den demokraten
im senat im kongress insgesamt jetzt
dieses verfahren anzufangen weil es die
alten gräben und sie haben die 74
millionen spieler angesprochen im grunde
genommen wieder vertiefen wird aber das
ist auch wichtig dass man auch nicht ein
präsident lassen kann nach eine wahl in
diesem wahlkreis november bis zum 20
januar alles frei zu tun was er will er
muss dann auch gehalten werden zu den
verfassungstext resende merke das ist
das wichtigste
politisch gesehen auf demokratischer
seite sie sagen es ist wichtig ein
zeichen zu setzen dieses verfahren zu
setzen denn nochmal meine nachfrage ich
glaube das alltagsgeschäft wird es nicht
erleichtern er hat sehr große pakete
konjunktur bewohner hilfspakete et
cetera es wird auch ein auf ein bisschen
konsens ankommen auch gerade im in der
gesellschaftliche in frage es sieht also
primär cana aber in der öffentlichkeit
auch keine umfragen deshalb 7 70 prozent
hinter den beiden das programm auch für
den krone ochse kämpfen und alle anderen
dann ist es eine frage der politische
wille im senat und im haus das
fortzusetzen oder ablenken zu können
an die amerikanische bevölkerung wird
erlaubt sehen wer ist dann auch für die
amerikaner
und wäre es für die partei es geht also
darum deutliche signale zu setzen wer wo
steht ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
informationen und einschätzungen james
die binde nagel ehemaliger
us-botschafter hier in deutschland
dankeschön für den besuch im studio
das ist vielen dank